three of the four Atlas aircrafts used
in the evaluation of British Nationals
from Sudan are reported to have
developed faults two-thirds of the
incoming Fleet is listed as unavailable
and there remains no Clarity the fleet
can perform the niche functions are
special air and board Services need
hasn't the Secretary of State made a
mistake in pressing ahead with ditch in
the Hercules feet in their favor
I've heard this sort of tired arguments
about what we really need to do is just
keep the hook and get rid of the l400i
performs the hurt on most tight it's got
a longer range bigger capacity you can
land in the same area in fact can land
in shorter distance and in Kabul of the
massive evacuation Can bull the a400 1A
400 had a fault for six hours and
managed to continue on its course the
over 100 is performing and as far as the
migration to Special Forces and other
capabilities that is on track already
having done jumps from it and other
parts of the area the simple reality is
over 100 outperforms it its availability
was extremely successful that the
Hercules only accounted for 10 of the
fleet and the overall Fleet for Lyft is
now the biggest it's been for 50 years
defense and security editor Deborah
Haynes has been following this story and
joins me now for more uh Deborah talk to
us about what's going to happen in this
instance
well the um the labor MP that asked the
question was quoting from the report
that we published a couple of hours ago
about these concerns
um around this decision to cut the C-130
Fleet it's not a new
um decision it happened back in 2021 but
and and the plan was that the a400m the
atlas which is a larger more capable
aircraft would take over the role from
the C-130 but the worry is that since
then you've had growing security threats
given Russia's full-scale invasion of
Ukraine there are also worries about the
availability of the a400 and I've seen
data that shows uh one day in early May
six Sorry Seven of those aircraft were
listed as being serviceable and the
other 14 were listed as being
unserviceable or unavailable for various
us different reasons and the problem
people have when they're looking at this
is that when you have a a certain number
of tasks that you want your transport
aircraft to perform but you have a
reduced number of actual planes that can
physically do that Transportation then
there is a greater risk and then the
other area is around the Special Forces
function so the C-130 has been in the
fleet for many years it first came into
service in 1999 it is much older but it
has got lots of special capabilities in
it that allow the Special Forces to do
the special things that they do that we
don't hear about and the concern is that
some of those a small number of those
Niche capabilities have yet to be
transferred over to the a400m now I have
been speaking to a defense Industry
Source who's been saying that the a400m
is capable of doing the range of Special
Forces missions but the RAF itself has
said there is going to be a gap in these
Niche capabilities at least until 2025.